Well these days it has been
very active and it is
releasing a lot of material, which is
this grit, ash, steam and some
other gases that we may not have
perceived until now, but it
is releasing a lot of material, we don't
know what what  It can happen
later, right, if we can have
an eruption of lava or mud or some other
material that could remove the
colossus, yes. So, well, yes, people
are afraid of those situations.
and be
alert alert Uh huh but yes first
when I tell him that he threw a lot of ashes
And yes I was a little scared but well
after that no longer Uh huh my
fear kind of went down
maybe he's also upset that they did
n't take him  their offering that every year they
bring to them on March 12 they bring
this one they
bring their molito they bring their this, that is,
everything to eat, they bring their suit and
they dance there and today they were not allowed to
go up to the best, that's why many
people say  that the volcano is annoying